[Musique]
et nous rejoint actuellement en plateau
mickaël millero le journaliste aux
sportifs de tv 78 bonsoir nous qu'est
bon sauvage ni alors du rugby pour
commencer avec du championnat de
fédérale 2 avis de tempête sur plaisir
ce dimanche 16 février l'équipe locale
en difficulté en fédérale 2 recevait
sous les bourrasques de vent un autre
prétendant la descente gennevillois
après avoir concédé l'ouverture du score
les plaisirs war réagissent et
réussissent à remporter la victoire sur
le score de 18 à 12
réaction mon sentiment c'est que c'était
pas le plus beau match de la saison
après les conditions c'est sûr faisait
que ça rendait les choses un peu plus
compliqué et beaucoup de vent mais bon
on s'en est quand même bien sorti
et ça donne une grosse bouffée d'oxygène
pour la suite la saison donc ça fait du
bien quoi une bouffée d'oxygène qui se
traduit au classement plaisir à dernier
il ya quelques semaines remonte à la 9e
place avec deux points d'avancé sur son
adversaire du jour
c'est la première fois de l'année qu'on
enchaîne de bons résultats 2 victoires
donc voilà j'espère que la dynamique va
pas s'arrêter à ces deux matches et puis
qu'on va pouvoir continuer à engranger
des points et on a un peu de confiance
quoi maintenant
j'ai un groupe qui est ambitieux j'ai
des joueurs qui sont ambitieux donc on
ira jusqu où on pourra aller avec grand
plaisir
pour continuer sa série de victoires
plaisir se déplacera sur le terrain de
beauvais ce dimanche 23 février le
deuxième de la poule
il y avait également du handball ce week
end en nationale 2 féminine
montigny-le-bretonneux s'est inclinée ce
week-end à l'extérieur chez saint
grégoire rennes métropole score final 24
à 22 malgré les neuf buts de kristen
d'elgato des gr k malgré cette défaite
montigny le bretonneux reste tout de
même troisième du classement prochain
match le 29 février à domicile contre
dreux merci michael on vous retrouve
dans quelques instants pour votre
émission le 7-8 sport